salut les coucous alors aujourd'hui je
participe à l'incroyable défi 24 heures
sans doute donc voilà j'ai commencé ma
journée par un petit café ah ouais non
du coup
les ondes c'est comme les drapeaux
bretons il y en a partout même dans
l'espace à moins que vous n'habitiez au
fond d'une grotte et encore il ya de
fortes chances pour que vous vous
preniez en ce moment même une douche
voluptueuse d'ondés électromagnétiques
en tout genre déjà si vous avez la
chance de voir le soleil désolé les
parisiens vous recevez en direct le type
d'ongles plus connue celle de la lumière
visible mais c'est qu'une toute petite
partie de la douche ondulatoire qu'on se
prend en continu les ondes dont je veux
vous causez séance ont des ondes
hertziennes c'est à dire des signaux
électromagnétiques qui n'ont pas besoin
de support matériel pour se propager
contrairement aux ondes sonores dans
l'espace personne ne vous entendra crier
mais vous verrez a explosé on peut
ranger ses ondes électromagnétiques en
fonction de leur fréquence si elle vibre
vite ou lentement en gros au sein de ce
qu'on appelle un spectre la lumière
visible c'est par ici au dessus on a les
ondes qui ont une fréquence plus élevée
et qui sont plus énergétiques dans
l'ordre les uv kg lapointe ont été les
rayons x qui nous permettent de voir
l'invisible et les rayons gamma émis par
les substances radioactives si vous
voulez plus d'infos là dessus je vous
renvoie vers mes vidéos sur le zircon
qui explique comment on a pu dater la
terre grâce à ce minéral radioactifs qui
est objectivement le plus merveilleux
d'humour mais les ondes qui vont nous
intéresser ici c'est celle qui
permettent de communiquer sans les mains
et surtout sans fil et de transporter
l'électricité
elles sont de l'autre côté du spectre
juste après les infrarouges y en a deux
sortes les ondes de haute fréquence et
celle de bosses tu recommences bon ben
voila je vous avouerai que c'est pas
ultra facile pour moi c'est mon café du
matin mais je me suis dit que j'allais
utiliser le micro mou la plaque de
cuisson mais du coup non voilà c'est pas
grave je me faire livrer un petit déj
à une hanche le wifi tu vas me manquer
les ongs haute fréquence c'est les
micros dont la fréquence est inférieur à
300 gigahertz et à dire que londres va
vibrer moins de 300 milliards de fois
par seconde elles servent aux
transmissions par satellite aux
téléphones portables à internet et aux
surprises au micro ondes pour réchauffer
vous lasagnes surgelées bande de petits
gastro lattre c'est aussi les ondes
émises et reçues par les talkie-walkies
des gendarmes pour communiquer et ou
distraire les manifestants la tnt pour
regarder d'eric hazan importante celle
des opérateurs téléphoniques pour
raconter à votre meilleur ami le dernier
épisode de derrick lahouari faille le
bleu tous les sons météo les antennes
relais la 5g pour distraire les antilles
vaste maison utilisée par les objets
connectés et la domotique en général les
satellites d'observation de la terre
pour surveiller les catastrophes
naturelles ou prédire la météo et puis
il ya aussi les ondes radios comme celle
tout simplement captée par le poste de
notre papa quand il écoute les grosses
têtes celles émises par les sous marins
pour se déplacer et ou distraire les
baleines certaines ondes émises par les
avions pour se repérer dans l'espace et
oudiste rares les mouettes et celle des
systèmes militaires
ensuite il ya les ondes basses
fréquences comme celles émises par les
lignes à haute tension où les machines
industrielles saison deux là ne sont pas
uniquement émises et reçues pour
communiquer sans fil il ya plein de
trucs qui en produisent juste pour le
fun en fait à partir du moment où un
appareil électrique est branché il va
émettre autour de lui un champ
électrique même s'il est éteint et si
l'état lui mais il émet en plus un champ
magnétique du coup pour faire simple on
peut parler de champs électromagnétiques
bon bah écoutez
j'ai pas la télé du coup j'ai loupé les
rediff de motus ça ça me pèse un peu
pour tout vous dire mais bon c'est pas
grave je m'occupe voilà donc j'ai un peu
de lecture je vous ai pas dit mais comme
j'ai pu de machines à laver du coup bas
chez les mêmes prières parlement vous
n'avez pas l'odeur avec
donc il ya plein de petits et gros
modules qui vont produire un des champs
électromagnétiques de nora ou voisinage
immédiat des lignes à haute tension
comme on l'a dit plus haut et ce qu'elle
soit aérienne ou souterraines diana
aussi autour des transformateurs des
serveurs informatiques et plus
généralement tous les appareils
électriques sous tension chez vous oui
vous en gros tous les machins qu'on peut
acheter chez partie du frigo à la lampe
à huile en passant par les plaques à
induction
les écrans d'ordinateurs et de télé pour
regarder la spéciale dj le set de dj
pour animer vos soirées disco le
ventilateur aussi pour aérer la pièce
parce que le lycra bas ça tient chaud
bref tout ça c'est des sources de basse
et très basse fréquence
j'avais oublié le réseau téléphonique la
3g et la 4g et tout ça du coup bah je
suis allé me perdre en pleine cambrousse
comme vous pouvez le voir ici je capte
edge c'est pas rien mais c'est le plus
proche que je puisse avoir de rien je
pense et puis voilà c'est cool ça me
fait découvrir un peu la france d'en bas
comme ça ces gens paître
vous l'aurez compris on baigne dans un
océan d'ondres permanence mais je vous
rassure tout de suite tout ça est bien
encadré forte heureusement il ya une
réglementation il ya des seuils à ne pas
dépasser et c'est surveillé de près par
un organisme public la nfl agence
nationale des fréquences qui va vérifier
régulièrement que le public n'est pas
exposé à des niveaux trop élevés les
diverses zones avec lesquels on cohabite
joyeuse j'ai dit quoi déjà les ondes
radios sont totalement différentes des
ondes radioactives ans par exemple les
ondes radios elles ne sont pas assez
énergétique pour venir jouer au bowling
avec les atomes de notre corps de rêve
c'est pas des ondes ionisantes donc ça
ses coûts et la plupart du temps
l'intensité des ondes est largement en
dessous des valeurs limites d'exposition
par exemple sur les quais de métro
parisien l'intensité des ondes reçues et
de 1,22 volts par mètre en moyenne
sachant que les valeurs limites
réglementaires sont entre 28 et 87 volts
par mètre et à la marge autre exemple
dans le cas des compteurs linky parce
que j'aime bien appuyer là où ça fait
mal hans hess l' agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail tout
annecy ça comme un chrono a conclu qu'il
n'y avait qu'une faible probabilité que
les compteurs communicants comme line
qui puisse engendrer des effets
sanitaires à court ou long terme dans la
configuration de déploiement actuel bon
j'ai pas trop l'habitude du soleil du
coup j'ai fait un petit malaise tout à
l'heure mais il ya des gentils gens de
la campagne qui sont venus apporter un
casse-croûte vraiment ils sont braves
ces gens ils n'ont rien mais il donne
tout et tant qu'on y est si on en
profitait pour faire un petit point sur
la 5g oui aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment
décidé de me faire des amis après la 3g
la 4g et l'huile d'olive au sujet voilà
t'y pas qu'on est en train de développer
sur tout le territoire la 5g sa
technologie bouleversante et disruptive
qui promet un débit jusqu'à dix fois
supérieur à celui de la 4g et qui
permettra non seulement de télécharger
plus vite un fond d'écran de bon goût
mais aussi de faire parler les objets
connectés entre eux voire de créer des
les connectés et pour la santé alors
est-ce que cinq jets d'engins et ben a
priori nolan cesse encore elle a publié
une étude en avril 2021 qui conclut en
ce sens ça falloir un peu entré dans la
technique pour aller plus loin faites
moi confiance pourrait bien se passer la
salle g est déployé sur trois bandes de
fréquences deux d'entre elles sont déjà
utilisées par la 3g et la 4g depuis des
années bah ça c'est une affaire qui
roule et même si les antennes se mettent
à émettre de la 5g en plus les niveaux
d'exposition au donc vous très peu varié
et la 5g va aussi être déployé sur une
nouvelle bande située à 3 5 giga hertz
d'après 27 au vu des données disponibles
il est peu probable que ça constitue un
nouveau risque pour la santé par contre
le vrai danger de la 5g n'est pas où on
imagine cette nouvelle bande de
fréquences que les opérateurs vont
utiliser et très proche de celle dont se
servent les météorologues pour
communiquer avec leurs satellites du
coup bah ça risque de brouiller les
échanges et de compliquer le travail de
nos miss météo pour prédire le temps
qu'il fera demain et pour surveiller le
climat c'est un fait pas du tout anodin
qui a provoqué un tollé de la part des
scientifiques heureusement malte en
trouver des solutions d'ici là puisque
le déploiement de la 5g dans cette bande
là n'est même pas encore planifié ni en
france ni en europe mais il va falloir
faire particulièrement gaffe à ça et
adapter les émetteurs avec des filtres
pour pas que que les messages se
mélangent voilà donc où est le réel
danger de la 5g
j'ai complètement oublié qu'en fait bas
la lumière le son ça aussi c'est des
ondes du coup j'ai plus qu'une chose à
faire c'est de m'enfermer dans une
grotte je vous dis au revoir maintenant
merci d'avoir suivi cet incroyable défi
24 heures s'en vont ne ratez pas le
prochain 24 heures à manger des
rillettes aller saluer abondance vous la
cloche
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
s'il vous plaît je vous invite à faire
preuve de bienveillance et d'amour dans
les commentaires comme toujours c'est
comme le saucisson on n'en a jamais trop
merci à mes pour buveurs sur youtube et
tu pues qui sont au moins aussi
merveilleux que zircon et je remercie
excellent d'avoir financé cette vidéo ex
m et un laboratoire toulousain
spécialisé dans la mesures de champ
électromagnétique pour contrôler
l'exposition du public et des
travailleurs ils ont développé
l'observatoire des ondes un site avec
plein de ressources autour des ondes et
qui permet au public de surveiller son
exposition aux ondes grâce aux capteurs
qui déploie sur le territoire allez donc
y jeter un oeil vous pouvez aussi
acheter
une pierre pour vous protéger des ondes
là bas non c'est pas vrai ils font pas
ce genre de truc quand à moi je vous dit
allô oui à salluit diego tu as vu le
dernier d'eric
[Musique]
pour la mauritanie
adata non
[Musique]
alstom
supprimer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le matin de paris
tiens